so here's the quarterback comparison
clearly the numbers in favor of the
rookie mac jones so uh big numbers here
stand out to you sim well i mean you
know the four interceptions is of course
huge but hey zach wilson i think we're
going to hear robert salas say this it's
not always going to be a highlight show
you're gonna have weeks in the nfl where
it's gonna be man it's ugly and we just
gotta find a way to win the football
game and don't let me lose it and he'll
learn that as he goes forward all right
you queued it up let's hear what robert
salah had to say
when you have a rookie quarterback and
you know and they have a rookie
quarterback too i mean shoot it's it's
just having confidence that it's okay to
play a boring game of football you know
that that's that's really it and he is
he is an electric dude he's competitive
he's crap he's and uh he wants to win so
bad but you know that's sometimes it's
okay to be boring and uh and that's
probably the biggest lesson that we can
take out of this one
all right so mac jones the more
impressive quarterback of the two this
afternoon but can we talk about the
patriots defense this was clinical for
what bill belichick is trying to instill
in this team what stood out to you most
well i think it's when it's all said and
done this is going to be one of the best
defenses in football they got tremendous
size up front so they can stop the run
just with their front seven but they're
well coached and talented in the
secondary so they're going to make some
plays every game getting hands on the
ball interceptions we saw last week
against tua and the dolphins and i think
that's the thing right now we're looking
like i was kind of just saying at the
end of that clip it's old school
patriots we're gonna run the ball
mac jones just make a few plays here and
there and our defense is really going to
shut down the other team's offense and
uh it's it's belichick football at its
finest i mean i think this defense is
just going to continue to go in the
right direction all right well one
person that would know a little bit
about that new england defense let's
bring back rodney and get his thoughts
uh rodney you watch this game closely
what did you think about new england's
defense and what they're trying to put
in play in new england catherine that's
easy money that's easy money anytime
coach belichick against a rookie
quarterback and we talked about this
that's easy money they're going to
disguise they're going to move around
they're going to put pressure in his
face they're going to do everything they
can to make his life absolutely
miserable and you look at juan bentley
this is a delayed blitz he's coming
right directly in his face and tips and
overthrows that's what we're always
talking we talk about as defensive backs
and that's just what they do jc jackson
had two interceptions he's been
outstanding like chris alluded to
but four interceptions
and only 19 points at that time and
chris you talked about the patriots
defense they're gonna get better and
better but the last two weeks they
couldn't stop the run and that's
something that's absolutely driving
coach belichick up the wall so they're
going to have to find a way to stop the
run continue with the turnovers but any
rookie quarterback against coach
belichick that's easy money i want to
ask you about another rookie quarterback
patriots defense we expect these kind of
performances out of them especially
going up against a rookie and zach
wilson but mack jones this offense seems
like it's at its best when he's throwing
the football how did he build on week
one today well they still have him
throwing these short intermediate routes
i would like to see him throw the ball
down the field more they're trying to be
a little bit more conservative trying to
protect mack mack is such a good uh
rookie quarterback you don't have to
protect him let him lose throw the ball
down the field let him do his thing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports